[Música]
en él
y
[Música]
no no
yo
[Música]
no
y
[Música]
an
no
[Música]
es genial que te haya pasado de no van a
creer no fue propósito yo hice mi vídeo
entero y acababa de otras formas pero es
genial que te haya pasado porque de lo
que yo vengo hablado hoy es precisamente
de esto
de la tecnología
[Música]
como nosotros interactuamos con la
tecnología mucho eso trabajo que te
vieron ahí no es un solo trabajo son
muchos vídeos que estaba haciendo por
año y yo intentaba contar mi historia yo
quería hacer una especie de biografía
con mis animaciones desde el principio
pero la tecnología me falló una vez más
lo cual es interesante porque esto me ha
estado pasando por años yo comencé
trabajando animación
primero que todo ya que esto no lo conté
entero yo fui a bellas artes estudió
pintura fue allá bond se llama pintura
fui a parsons volviendo de pintura
y en mi último año en nueva york
y dije hay algo que no encaja hay algo
que falta en la
una pintura está en la pintura y hay
algo que falta que yo no quería hacer
eso yo quería hacer otra cosa yo me crié
en capotillo barrio muy pobre mis padres
eran pobres no había antes yo no sabía
lo que era un cuadro yo nunca había una
pintura hasta que tenía como 16 años
pero cuando yo era niño
yo tenemos me quito en el colegio
amiguitos rico
que él tenía los get de star wars y
obviamente violencia mi papá que me
compraran lo que testar wolf era muy
caro
eran exageradamente caro un action fidel
costaba como 5 pesos
eso era todo lo cual todo el mundo
entonces
no sé cómo pasó eso exactamente pero en
un momento yo decidí si no me lo voy a
comprar porque no es razonamiento como
el papel sigue trayendo metí que arco y
flecha
tú sabes
un juguete [ __ ] pero también una
palabra
yo veo que este nuevo funcionario voy a
hacer yo creo que juguete
mi charla yo la he llamado the wine
urbana y refiriéndome
a este término que se ha acuñado ahora
con el western south
o hazlo tú mismo yo crecí en un barrio y
ni idea de eso creo que en esa época
tampoco había ese concepto
pero ya yo tenía el concepto en la mente
interesante de todo esto es que yo crecí
como le dije me metí a bellas arte
porque fue común
lo natural llegó un momento de todo el
mundo y dijeron ese muchachito dibuja
demasiado llegó no voy a hacerte más el
problema es que ya al final de todos los
estudios yo dije yo creo que reconectar
con lo que yo hacía de pequeño
que algo un poquito más libre donde yo
no tengo que ser rembrandt ni picadas
son y van gogh
entonces yo comencé a hacer
estos títeres es muy parecido a la
fabricación que yo tenía cuando era niño
como títere que era que yo cogía
botella plástica de color o lapicero
cualquier cosa decía el propio juguete
yo sé a transformers así a star wars
toda la colección
la verdadera star wars no vaya
discúlpeme de nuevo
la idea es esa entonces
esa es la conexión que yo tuve ahí fue
ayudado porque un poquito
en nueva york yo tuve contacto con
artistas que aquí no tenían contacto y
el contacto con su artista me dijo
espérate que uno tiene que hacer
pinturas necesariamente te gusta la
pintura el dibujo muy chulo pero eso no
eres tú tanto tú eres más otra cosa
y ese contacto me llevó a experimentar
experimentar experimentar entonces qué
pasa con que el vídeo se friso de
interesante que pasara esto porque
cuando pasó el cambio de lo análogo a lo
digital entre 2001 y pico comenzó todo
va a cambiar yo comencé trabajando la
primera animación con una camarita
highlight
pero a lo mejor nunca han oído hablar de
eso no hay un milímetro película es lo
que yo quería hacer pero yo no podía
comprarlo yo me compré una cámara de
vídeo hair lo cual era una resolución
como quien dice que tú coge un celular y
coge la pantallita una tercera parte es
en la resolución que te tiene bueno el
caso es que yo comencé trabajando con
eso propuesto cambio digital cuando todo
cambio digital yo no estaba alerta de lo
que estaba pasando yo lo veía todo muy
maravilloso y muy fácil pero de repente
toda la data está en la nube
y en la nube se pierden se dañan o disco
duro pasan este tipo de cosas y eso me
costó me comenzó a dejar frustraciones
eventualmente lo que yo comencé a hacer
fue preocuparme mucho por como yo hago
que yo pueda volver a tener
lo que yo estoy haciendo de una manera
táctil real
un barco digamos así seguro no algo que
depende de que sí el decoro se dañó y
ese tipo de cosas en este proceso he
comenzado
después de perder varios disco duro y
hay mucha información hubo un momento en
que yo me paré dijo keith no puedo con
esto yo no puedo embarcarme en otra
animación y perder todo mi trabajo o
tener que pagar muchísimo dinero para
recuperarlo
yo quiero algo que yo me sienta como yo
me sentía antes y lo que hice fue decir
bueno
lo mejor que podría hacer es usar
películas rollos de película
como en los viejos tiempos
y en ese proceso comencé a investigar me
di cuenta de que tenía que desempolvar
lo todo de volver a conectar con las
cosas la tecnología digital
como fotógrafo te hace
se hace muy responsable porque hay
muchas formas de tu mantener
[Música]
una buena imagen sin tú realmente hacer
nada entonces volver a la fotografía
análoga me hizo retomar un poquito más
con lo que verdaderamente se identifica
conmigo yo soy un poquito tenista se
darán cuenta del vídeo y de alguna forma
en todo este proceso yo comencé
hacer mi propia cámara
a partir de madera
simplemente para cómo llegar a un
entendimiento mayor de las cosas de todo
esto no es necesario obviamente tú
puedes comprar una cámara vieja ebay
en 50 dólares
yoga tema de 50 dólares
desde aquí en la parte de atrás de la
cámara me fui en una no fue una y
comencé a usar película 120 y este es
como la parte de atrás donde se engancha
el rollo
aquí está la cámara un poquito más
acabada
y aquí estaba una primera prueba con un
lente esto que ven aquí esto que ven
aquí que esa madera que sale es la forma
de capturar la luz porque aquí no hay
mostrador o sea no hay un clic
entonces yo habría dejado que entraba y
cerrado
teherán el tipo se fue una idea y no
sabes pero salieron foto solo cuesta
nada
ok ahí estoy haciendo mi primer
experimento en el parque colón en el
sitio favorito de toda la vida porque
tiene cuatro árboles muy importante para
mí
otra tenemos
en todas mis investigaciones me comenzó
a interesar por esto que llaman pinhole
cámara hay un término en español que se
me escapa
pero esto es que no hay lentes hay un
ojito en la parte de la mente tú vas a
que entre luz por un determinado tiempo
y tu captura una imagen así y aquí hizo
una especie de disparador
y lo que van a ir en la película que
tengo adentro
para yo enfocar esto yo tengo que quitar
la parte de atrás donde está la película
poner esta especie de
acordeón
y en la foto original ustedes vamos a
ver cómo se refleja la imagen que está
allá atrás que es el árbol
lo que hay aquí me fue un poquito más
pro y decidí montar le un lente que
tiene un mostrador
para no volverme tan loco y esto es otro
de mis procesos que es que
de nuevo yo compro película
y tengo que enrollarla en rollo más
pequeño
y de repente está un aparatico que yo
hice para meter mi película grande y
enrollarla a los 25 dólares
etc
pero hacerlo pero se siente mucho más
pero cuando te saca algo de ahí
y esto es de las imágenes que han salido
de allí
esto con la cámara en hall
hay que calcular la exposición esto fue
en el parque ahí todavía determinando un
poquito el enfoque porque el tamaño del
hoyo determinar enfoque
bien porque hay demasiado luz
estos son los árboles del parque también
este dedo para el que sale
esto también es interesante porque esta
imagen de una cortina
y se ve como un espejo
esta posición duró como 18 minutos para
conseguir esta imagen verdad lo
interesante es que yo dejo mi cámara y
se te hará frente a este cuarto y me voy
porque pongo el cronómetro son 18
minutos cuando vuelvo a mi papá movió la
cámara
o sea
europa tiene 89 años y el tipo se ha
decidido a los 89 años ser activo en mi
obra de arte
está en todas partes
ok esto con la cámara pinhole y no sé
muy bien tampoco pero esa imagen
fantasma mía que hay
una de las diferentes posiciones
y yo me muevo en un sitio me quedo fijo
luego me muevo del 7 y queda como es el
reflejo fantasma
aquí todo yo varias veces
igual
esto es película síntoma mente
ok entonces
para mí es como muy importante el poder
es reconectar con eso yo voy a tratar de
poner otro vídeo ahora si pasa
donde yo estoy haciendo dobles
posiciones estoy cogiendo
exponiendo la película una vez
enrollando la de nuevo y volviendo a
exponer el caso con todo esto que
hubiera la experimentación es
precisamente llegar a poder hacer
animación
con película y que me quede me bajo que
dura 100 años y no se daña
[Música]
no no no
a
[Música]
esto era cuando estaba haciendo esa
última animación ahí lo que venga atrás
es otro invento que dice que fue montar
un rollo a una cámara nikon
que haya de fábrica para poder hacerlo
como si fuera una película desarrollando
cada vez que tomó una foto y es el
proceso de animación que yo estoy
haciendo precisamente
[Música]
pero no eso no se acaba nunca señores
ok se me está acabando el tiempo porque
mucho tiempo con la repetición del vídeo
pero
en definitiva
en el van a mí o definitivamente yo
puedo conectar con las cosas que son
reales y para mí la cosa que son reales
son procesos anoche estaba en una
exposición y un fotógrafo viejo análogo
muy bueno me comenzó a atacar que porque
yo estoy haciendo fotografía análoga en
esta época que que lo que pasa yo le
dije el proceso
por qué
no hay diversión en darle a un clic y
que una computadora haga la cosa por ti
la diversión para mí yo hacerlo
y ahí está mi conexión con lo que yo
entiendo que lo espiritual con lo que yo
entiendo que es más profundo yo le
agradezco que hayan dedicado un poquito
de su tiempo para escuchar y ver mis lo
que heras pasen buen día